the cube root of x is in there as a
special example because it is probably
the most commonplace example of a point
of inflection that doesn't have a second
derivative at the point of inflection it
is a point of inflection because it fits
the definition is it changing from
cavity concave up concave down just like
a normal one down up whatever there's a
change okay however you can't find if
you were if you did a question it's like
find the points of inflection the normal
thing you would do instinctively is go
to the second derivative but you will
find no solutions there instead you will
find there's no second derivative okay
so it's just as important to look for
discontinuities of the second derivative
as it is to look for zero values okay
that that also should make you
suspicious okay so if for example we'll
not for example let's do like this if
the question were just as straight as
possible find the points of inflection
of this graph and suppose you never you
hadn't heard my example before you're
like oh you don't know that you're
guaranteed to find your point inflection
here's what you would do just like usual
you would differentiate once you
differentiate again right and what
you're doing is you're searching for
where points of inflection may occur
okay so the first thing is the first
question you ask you is is there any
place where the second derivative is
zero you don't get any values the second
derivative is never equal zero for this
particular curve such search for the
secretary of being equal to zero but
even if that never happens you should
also search for discontinuities
okay so question mark so you're
searching for both of these right and
it's not that hard to search for places
where a graph doesn't exist it's just
like if you get given this you remember
when we were talking about um rational
functions like this guy the
discontinuities are where the
denominator is zero so you're like oh x
equals negative two x equals five I'm
very good at spotting discontinuities
right well this thing he has written in
a bit of a messy form this is minus two
over 9x to the five on three
so clearly x equals zero might not give
me a second derivative but it does give
me a discontinuity that makes me
suspicious okay something might happen
here so then I test on either side of my
discontinuity right so I'm gonna get
something that looks just like this with
one difference there's no second
derivative at that particular point but
I see that I've got something on the
left something on the right that changes
okay there is probably one more
important thing to mention which is a
phrase I might actually highlight to
everyone
hey everyone sorry I wrote something
down on the board as a memory cue for
myself and then I failed to remember it
if you wrote down this first sentence I
like a lot of people do when they see
notes on the board what I want you to do
is highlight something that maybe
doesn't look obvious which is the phrase
a point so they have a point of
inflection you need there to be a point
now that seems obvious you can't have an
on point of inflection but let me tell
you why this is important this cube root
of x guy right so sorry I forgot to
mention this before this cube root of x
its second derivative is never zero it
never happens right because here it is
here's the second derivative there's no
value of x you can stick in there that
gives you a second derivative of zero
okay but what you do find is that second
derivative has a discontinuity you're
like oh I I can't put in x equals there
zero there so maybe something happens on
either side so you go ahead and you test
this is what it would look like okay no
four wannabe 4-0 but you'll get no
second derivative here but you see the
change in concavity on either side so
you're like cool thumbs up okay
however and I know it seems weird that I
keep on doing this but I think it's a
lot easier to understand this topic with
concrete concrete examples rather than
some area fairy like this may happen
somewhere in the future think about a
simple graph like this and we all know
what this shape is and what it looks
like okay let's see what happens when we
apply the tools of calculus to it this
is of course just X to the negative one
right so therefore the first derivative
is going to be equal to what minus X to
the minus 2 yeah I am interested in
points of inflection so I'm going to go
to the next derivative which in this
case is going to be 2 X to the negative
3 ok now if I apply the same kind of
logic that I did before I say is the
second derivative is this guy ever zero
and the answer is no this is two on X
cubed so they value you can put it near
that make it zero you get close to zero
but never zero so this never happens
I don't need discontinuities for the
second derivative and the answer is yes
there are yes there are at x equals zero
you have a discontinuity you can't put
that value in so using the process that
I've just shown you you get suspicious
and you say maybe something happens on
either side now let's actually do this
let's see what happens
sure are for me a table here's our X
values here's our second derivative
the point where suspicious about is x
equals zero that's where I know there is
no second derivative so maybe something
weird happens on either side
give me some values in this case this is
sufficiently close okay this this graph
is not doing too much crazy wiggling
around so that's alright when we put in
negative 1/2 times negative 1 to the
power of negative 3 what is that because
that sorry that is just negative 1 so
I'll put in a value there like I said
you have to put an actual number you
can't just say - when you put in 1 what
happens this is easier that's just to
see you like ah Co came down concave up
there's a change you can cavity just one
little catch of course remember we said
before we know what this graph looks
like right we know what it looks like
concave down yes concave up yes is there
a point of inflection and the answer is
well there's no point to begin with
there's no like where am I okay so the
hyperbola has no point of inflection
even though there's a change in
concavity which is why I said a point of
inflection occurs at a point you have to
be able to find that spot it's not just
a changing cavity in general which this
has there's a changing in cavity but
there's nowhere that actually occurs so
there's no point of inflection does that
make sense okay